on commence à peine à le découvrir mais
les islandais le consomme depuis mille
ans le skieur au marché jean talon de
montréal nous allons faire découvrir
trois de ces yoghourts danse et
protéines et que laisser vos disquaires
non non pas vraiment j'aurais dit
reste avec vous qu'il faut s'habituer à
ce que vous connaissez le ski non non à
l'amérique
y c'est ce serait une sorte et c'est
vraiment le goût de l'enfance ase j'ai
grandi en france et quand on retourne et
en islande pour noël ou pour des
vacances c'était toujours un peu
l'occasion spéciale de manger du skieur
qu'on ne trouvait pas ailleurs
et chaque fonctionne en islande j'en ai
trouvé dans le frigo c'est vraiment un
produit de base comme le yaourt ou comme
le lait ici il ya énormément de tourisme
en islande on retrouve vraiment un rayon
très fourni avec toutes les toutes les
saveurs différentes plusieurs marques
différentes de ce qui est assez
similaire à rayons de réussir le skieur
est apparue récemment sur nos tablettes
d'épicerie six compagnies les offres en
version nature ou aromatisé
voici les trois tirs nature qu'on
propose à nous booster
c'est sûr et sain comme le fromage eux
les zambiens la texture 12h06 un peu
assis puis je trouve plus concentré de
roger plus sûres il est somptueux
mais
légèrement acide face et qui agit elle
mange tout ça moi je ne mangerai pas
domaine tout seul nature au pot c'est
beaucoup moins intéressant que je pense
que très peu des sondés qu'ils
mangeraient comme ça on me lance avec
autre chose donc comme moi dans ma
famille c'était avec du lait et des
bleuets et du sucre ans en raison de sa
texture est passé en tueuse le squer
fait d'excellentes trempette et
vinaigrette
on utilise aussi en remplacement de la
crème dans les mas fun les desserts
glacés et même les glaçage à gâteau
ça manque de goût un peu
cela aussi
mallet plus entre eux plus pp à chaque
fois je suis surpris en recevant
beaucoup plus acide que que les yaourts
on a presque l'impression citronnée en
fait tellement ces acides
[Musique]
mais des gens n'est plus doux je le
connais absolument pas j'ai jamais vu ce
pôle avant et un missile des
iconographies pour dire 0 % de gras ça
aide à la formation des muscles pour
cuisiner serait le jeune j'aurais du mal
à décrire ce qui est vraiment une
différence actuelle ce qui risque d où
le skieur qu'on retrouve dans dix ans la
seule chose que je sais depuis que je
suis tout petit c'est que c'est pas un
yaourt
c'est un fromage donc beaucoup plus
proche du fromage blanc qu'on va
retrouver en europe
c'est un produit qui est riche en
protéines et au niveau de sa contenance
en matières grasses
en fait il n'a pratiquement pas donc il
est on va dire du lait écrémé en général
non plus qui s'apprend cap tasse de lait
pour faire une taxe de ce qui est en
général le yogourt grec ce à peu près
entre 2 et 3 càs de lait pour faire un
yogourt
donc c'est pour ça que le ski est un
produit qui est assez concentrés au
niveau de sa texture
après les salles bio c'est la bleue oui
m
moi j'aime bien
c'est quoi
francine le djembé abbas a rappelé la
campagne un peu moins amère mais plus
consistant
les deux sont issus
leur trouve un maul l'islande avec les
glaciers visuellement la texture à leur
différend alors s'il est étonnamment il
est différent ils me rappellent -
peut-être le cirque que je pouvais
manger en islande est beaucoup plus
proche du yaourt en train de goût il ya
moins cette acidité immédiate qu'on a le
blues est plus doux et dont les tours à
l'oeil
plus clément étonnamment il ya quand
même plusieurs islandais maintenant qui
habite à montréal il ya vraiment une
nouvelle tradition que mélanger ça avec
du sirop d'érable
sarko c'est vraiment là le mariage des
deux cultures c'est c'est les mêmes les
et sans discernement et non ça c'est ça
ça marche vraiment bien sirop d'érable
et ce qui est assez amer chose au monde
alors le verdict est tombé sig et ce
huit votes danone 16 et 26 goûteurs ont
préféré le liberté qui est notre grand
gagnant aujourd'hui
merci à nos buteurs
[Musique]